vous en avez assez il suffit de regarder
votre ticket de caisse pour vous en
rendre compte la vie coûte désormais
plus cher les ménages sont rattrapés par
l'inflation mais également les
entreprises elles voient leur coût
augmenter et les conditions de
financement ce durcir alors tous les
secteurs sont-ils logés à la même
enseigne il y en a-t-il qui sont
épargnés voire même qui profitent de
cette situation économique en bref qui
sont les perdants et les gagnants de
l'inflation
l'inflation peut parfois devenir une
occasion certains secteurs et acteurs
économiques sont épargnés voire tire
partie de l'augmentation des prix
certaines entreprises réalisent même des
super profits je crois qu'on peut
clairement dire que les compagnies
pétrolières ont été gagnantes en France
on a eu l'exemple de Total qui a affiché
un profit de plus de 20 milliards de
dollars donc à peu près autant en euros
qui est un profit historique pour
l'entreprise pour Total énergie d'autant
que les 20,5 milliards doivent être
augmentés d'une perte exceptionnelle qui
a été passée au titre des actifs russes
qui ont dû être cédés de 15 milliards
donc quelque sorte en vrai total énergie
à gagner 36 milliards de dollars l'année
dernière ce qui s'explique par un
phénomène assez simple ils extraient du
pétrole qu'ont raffiner donc en quelque
sorte il y a une sorte de double effet
cliquet gagnant l'année dernière les
prix du brut étaient de 42 près de 43%
supérieur à ceux qu'ils avaient atteint
en 2021 d'où des super profit l'énergie
pétrolière n'est d'ailleurs pas le que
le secteur attiré profit de l'inflation
les Français aujourd'hui cherchent les
bonnes affaires au moment où le prix de
leur panier de course a considérablement
augmenté une tendance qui favorise
l'achat chez les discounters qui
semblent donc tirer leur épingle du jeu
dans le secteur ultra concurrentiel de
la consommation les discounters sont
effectivement les grands gagnants de
l'inflation on a d'un côté les
discounters alimentaires donc les
distributeurs notamment allemand Aldi à
Lidl qui ces derniers mois ont été ceux
qui ont le plus gagné de parts de marché
elle dit aujourd'hui c'est 3% de part de
marché Lidl c'est plus de 8% donc il y a
une assez nette progression et puis on a
les discounters non alimentaires par
exemple des actions stokomani La
Foir'Fouille qui soit en fait des
discounteurs qui vont aller déstocker
les stocks d'autres enseignes ou
d'autres marques ou qui vont aller
s'approvisionner sur des circuits
alternatifs par exemple en allant
acheter les produits en Pologne dans les
pays de l'Est ce qui permet de proposer
des prix cassés aux Français un autre
distributeur qui est devenu presque un
phénomène de société c'est le
néerlandais action qui a aujourd'hui
crise ou pas crise ouvre tous les ans 70
magasins avec à chaque fois une foule
qui se presse aux portes des magasins
tout simplement parce que les Français
ont compris que ils pouvaient trouver
des prix cassés là-bas aujourd'hui c'est
9 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en augmentation de 30% et
c'est le premier disqueur d'un
alimentaire dans l'Hexagone on voit que
l'inflation fait les affaires de
secteurs liés à l'approvisionnement
assez logiquement ceux qui perdent tout
change lorsque les prix augmentent sont
les secteurs qui utilisent la matière
première pour créer des biens et des
logements avec en première ligne le
secteur du BTP l'inflation un impact sur
les coûts de fabrication que ce soit
l'acier l'aluminium le béton ou les
tuiles ont subi des très fortes hausses
de prix ces derniers mois le béton a
subi une hausse de 17% depuis le début
de l'année du côté des acheteurs
ils doivent donc assumer des prix en
hausse dans le même temps le financement
de projet devient plus difficile
l'inflation fait grimper les taux
d'intérêt et cela crée une restriction
des conditions de crédit cela a un
impact important dans le secteur de la
construction depuis le début de l'année
les permis de construire sont en baisse
de 26% sur le premier trimestre ce qui
est énorme la Fédération française du
bâtiment estime que d'ici 18 à 24 mois
il y a pas moins de 100000 emplois qui
sont menacés dans le secteur l'industrie
lourde particulièrement dépendante du
prix de l'énergie et du coût des
matières premières se trouve fortement
impactés par l'inflation sans autre
solution que de réduire la production
l'industrie qui est vraiment affectée
c'est ce qu'on appelle les énergos
intensifs c'est à dire des gros
consommateurs d'énergie c'est à dire que
soit de gaz soit électricité dans les
processus de production par exemple
c'est les fabricants d'acier d'aluminium
ou de verre à l'automne il y a un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui ont décidé
de réduire leur niveau de production
pour pouvoir payer de ces prix de
l'énergie aluminium Dunkerque qui est le
plus gros producteur d'aluminium en
Europe
a ainsi baissé sa production de 22% Arc
International les cristalleries bien
connus ont eux fermé la moitié de leur
de leur four verriers on peut dire
clairement qui sont perdants d'inflation
[Musique]